Sarah Palin was asked to explain why
trumpism is not a cult and she explained
why trumpism is a cult this is a really
really stunning video and it confirms
just about everything we've been talking
about for years now Sarah Palin appeared
on Newsmax and she was basically given
one of these softball questions where
it's like Trump people aren't cultists
right and Sarah Palin goes absolutely
not because cultists are and then she
defines it and she is of course
describing trumpists take a listen to
this I was with the Trump motorcade
yesterday and I would say that the
people at Versailles at the Cuban
restaurant I wouldn't call them cult
members would you
uh no you know the definition of a cult
is a group of people who are excessively
supporting what another and a cause all
about Conformity and compliance and
intolerance of anyone who doesn't agree
with what their mission is okay that's
the definition of what the left is
engaged in right now speaking of Colts
all about Conformity and compliance and
heaven forbid you don't agree with them
isn't that the best by just about any
accurate definition
hardcore Maga is indeed a cult they have
beliefs and practices that are strange
or even Sinister including denying the
reality of the world insofar as climate
change covid the 2020 election results
they worship Trump as this Messianic
figure
who can do no wrong must be obeyed at
all costs and many of them even see him
as a pseudo deity they are characterized
by their devotion not only to Trump but
the ideology he espouses which they
often express through symbols including
Maga hats or Flags or banners or signs
and symbols they have a system of
beliefs that are
pseudo-religious and rituals which are
directed towards Trump they pray for him
or they pray over him as we saw at the
Cuban Cafe Versailles in Miami on
Tuesday they attend his rallies and
chant his slogans they storm the capital
on his behalf committing crimes on his
behalf and they have this self-appointed
leader Trump
who claims to be the only one
that can save them that can save America
and they believe it these are all cult
traits and of course Trump for his part
of it excessively controls his followers
through lies fear threats manipulation
requiring them to believe what he says
and to do what he wants donating or
voting or chanting or whatever the case
may be and these are all beliefs that
most of the world considers deviant or
depraved and much of the United States
as well compare this to Biden supporters
okay Biden supporters aren't obsessed
with symbols or rituals Biden supporters
aren't obsessed with Biden in fact most
of us don't even really care about Joe
Biden like what I mean by that is I
don't want harm to come to him but I
don't care about Biden as a figure
I'm not interested in defending Biden if
he did something wrong if he did
something wrong investigate him or
charge him or whatever I'm interested in
policy and I'm interested in ideas and
if Biden is going to be the person to
push those that's great and if it's
somebody else that's fine too we don't
consider Biden the ultimate source of
Truth the way maggots consider Trump to
be I don't consider MSNBC or whatever
Democratic establishment media is out
there to be the ultimate source of Truth
the way they consider whether it's Fox
News or Newsmax or whatever is the
flavor of the month to be an ultimate
source of truth I don't feel any need to
reflexively defend Biden against any
criticism yeah Biden's just not
Progressive enough on some policies yeah
Biden's looking dramatically more frail
than he used to yeah I also don't see
criticisms of Biden
as a tax on the Free World on Democracy
on the media on our country
okay criticize Biden I'll tell you if I
agree or if I disagree it is a dramatic
contrast when you think about what it
means to be in a cult occult member
occult leader and Sarah Palin
hilariously and trying to say no no no
no there's no cult here actually
confirmed there is indeed a cult
in the middle of the AI craze of today
it's easy to forget the beginning years
of the I.T industry let me take you back
to 1989. imagine living in a world
without the internet and without mobile
phones forget about smartphones the it
business in India was in its infancy one
of the largest Indian I.T companies
Infosys was just starting offshore
projects our sponsor ithal is promoting
his new non-fiction book called
confessions of an Indian immigrant dawn
of I.T opportunities in the land of
promise it really takes us down memory
lane narrating his experiences
immigrating from Mumbai to New York and
the culture shock a company
headquartered in New York hired him and
it had given its first project to
Infosys which is now this multi-billion
dollar company with thousands of
employees and as the title suggests the
story combines his EXP experiences
settling down in the U.S at the dawn of
the I.T industry adjusting to social
life in the U.S including American
Business culture and this book really
has something for everyone whether
you're interested in Tech immigration
culture or you just like a good
autobiography pick up your copy at
davidpackman.com
confessions the link is in the
description